Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 219 to David P. Here's a caller
who is disgusted with the hate mob unleashed
upon me by donald trump jr. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hi, david. I just saw your
video regarding the tweet you removed.
I think you did the right thing. But removing
it, i guess because. Imagine the hypocrisy of
these people there. First of all, anyone
who knows who listens to you should know
exactly what you meant by that tweet. Of course,
that's disturbing. But the fact that they would
threaten you and your family. Come on, people.
Speaker 1: This is what they do.
Speaker 6: It's just just disgusting. Yes. And you
are correct. Obviously, if thoughts and prayers
stop this, we wouldn't have this problem.
And I do agree. You know, I think people if
they if prayer works for them, that's great do
that. But we need to take action legislatively.
Speaker 1: Pray but allow
politicians to do things.
Speaker 6: You know, and call and write and just
press our all our representatives on the local,
state and federal level. This is
inexcusable. And one thing that I
feel like never gets discussed really in the
mainstream media at least, is the fact that
the GOP is in bed with the NRA, of course.
Speaker 1: And in fact, in my video that I
did yesterday, I do discuss it because it must be
discussed. Accurate voice mail. I have nothing to
add. We have a great voice. A bonus show for you
today. We will talk about Joe Biden's reaction
to the Nashville shooting and his urging of an
assault weapons ban. We're also going to talk
about hand scanning technology rolled out
at Panera that has privacy advocates very
concerned. Are they warranted in being concerned?
We will discuss. And lastly, a conspiracy theory
about a body double for John Fetterman
has actually gotten a bunch of attention.
It's pretty nuts. We will talk about
all of it on the bonus show. Sign up.
Join pack Mint.com. Use the coupon code.
Cancel. Cancel to get yourself a discount.